what was once a pristine lake with
Emerald Waters in Bosnia and Herzegovina
is now blanketed with plastic waste it's
filled with up to 15 000 cubic meters of
Driftwood plastic bottles tires and
household appliances the debris has been
building up for years in visigrad
residents like Veritas say she's paying
the price for an issue that's not been
addressed
after all these years more than 20 years
of living alongside the river we had to
accept this as a fact of life of course
we tend to believe that we will die
before the dreamers clean off garbage
cheese
the Drina river runs from the
mountainous areas in the northwest of
Montenegro through Serbia and Bosnia
changing weather patterns has led to
waste flowing into waterways with
garbage stuck behind a trash barrier
near a hydroelectric power plant and
much of the rubbish is dumped in poorly
regulated Riverside landfills covering
Hills and Valleys environmental
activists say the floating health hazard
will take months to clear and want more
action from the authorities
I appeal to the government to establish
something like a proper waste management
system because the municipality no fault
of our own was turned two decades ago
into a regional waste dump
environment Ministers of Bosnia Serbia
and Montenegro have promised to work
together to solve the problem but time
is running out for residents who have to
live with the trash piling up as their
beautiful River becomes a rubbish dump
rahila Muhammad al-jazeera